لنفهم الوضع اكثر على الجبهات ينضم الينا
من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اللواء دويري ماذا
تفهم من زياده وتيره استخدام المسيرات
خاصه من قبل اوكرانيا
لا هذه مسار موازي لمسار العمليات
العسكريه البريه بعد تعثر الهجوم المضاد
الذي تم الحديث مطولا عنه وتم الاعداد له
تم تاخير ساعه الصفر او ساعه البدء
لاسابيع ولعده مرات
وكان الجميع يتوقع او الغالبيه العظمى ان
هذه العمليات ستسير بالمقاربه الغربيه او
حسب العقائد القتاليه الغربيه والتي طبقت
في منطقه خاركيف في منتصف عام 2022 ولكن
كان هناك واقع مختلف جدا من حيث شبكات
التحصينات والخطوط الدفاعيه وبالتالي لم
يحقق المعمول لا بل تم الحديث ان ما جرى
ويجري حتى هذه اللحظه هي المرحله
التمهيديه وان الجهد الرئيسي لم يتم زجه
بعد ذلك جعل على جسر كرش وتزامن مع انتهاء
اتفاقيات الحبوب وهنا سلكت اوكرانيا او
القوات الاوكرانيه مسارا موازيا لادامه
الحديث عن الحرب والحاجه الى الاسلحه
ولفرض شروط معينه فبدات باستخدام الطائرات
المسيره
هذا المسار المواسي الى اي حد يزعج روسيا
عسكريا
عسكريا الازعاج محدود ولكن الازعاج في
الابعاد الاخرى السياسيه الاقتصاديه
الاجتماعيه لانه الان الشعب الروسي حتى
موسكو لا اقول بالمطلق بدا يشعر انه ضمن
منطقه عمليه وبالتالي لها ردودها ولا
تكلفتها وفاتوره التكاليف لكن كانجاز
عسكري قد يكون في منطقه شبه جزيره القرم
اكثر تاثيرا ونجاعه وفاعليه
عندما تهاجم الجسور الرئيسيه من شبه جزيره
القرم الى خرسون او لجسر كيرش الذي يتصل
مع البر الروسي وتؤثر على طرق الامداد
تهاجم الى غير ذلك نعم هناك تلقي بظلالها
العسكري الزوارق البحريه
دمرت او عصابه او اعطبت سفينه انزال
وناقله نفط هذا التاثير العسكري تقريبا
يظهر جليا في شبه جزيره القرم وليس داخل
روسيا طيب
حتى الان لا تبدو روسيا بانها تستطيع
مواجهه هذا الكن من المسيرات
هل تستطيع ان تطبع مع هذا الواقع روسيا اي
ان تبقى عرضه لاستهداف مسيرات في العمق
الروسي وفي شبه جزيره القرم
يعني
الامن المطلق غير لا يمكن تحقيقه وغير
موجود وعليها ان تتعايش وعليها ان تحدد
نقاط الضعف وعليها ان تطور تقنيات
المواجهه اما ان نقول ان دوله ما سوار
روسيا او غيرها لا يمكن لها ان تحقق الامن
المطلق وسيتم اختراق امنها وتصل الطائرات
المسيره لانه هناك عوامل كثيره تساعد على
هذا الاختراق سواء انواع الطائرات
قابله للتخفي غير قابله على خطوط الطيران
الارتفاع الحجم يعني امور كثيره جدا ندخل
في تفصيلات فنيه وبالتالي لكن انه نلاحظ
ان روسيا تتحدث في معظم الحالات عن
النجاحات كبيره في اسقاط هذه الطائرات لكن
دعني اوصف الحرب الروسيه خلال 18 شهر
اتذكر المثل في بلاد الشام حسابات
الحقل والبيدر لم لا يمكن ان يتطابقوا
لماذا لان الامكانات التي تم حشدها
والوسائل التي تم اعتمادها والاهداف التي
يتم تحقيقها الوسائل والامكانات لا ترقى
لمستوى الاهداف سواء في العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه الخاصه او في الهجوم المضاده
الاوكراني الوافاس الدويري في عمان شكرا
لك